We Begin this morning with new warnings
about the Corona virus this holiday
weekend and the continued need for
social distancing and the wearing of
masks president Trump and Dr Anthony
fouchy the country's top infectious
disease expert are encouraging Americans
to be careful and to use common sense
with any of their social Gatherings this
comes after there were increases in coid
cases over the Memorial Day and Fourth
of July Holidays fouchi put seven states
on notice North and South Dakota Iowa
Missouri Arkansas ill inois and Indiana
following recent jumps in their
infection rates more than 50,000 new
coron virus cases were reported on
Friday that is the most in a single day
this month pushing the total number of
infections in the US to more than 6.2
million Michael George is here in New
York with the latest Michael good
morning good morning Dana here in New
York malls and casinos are set to reopen
this week but the plan to reopen City
schools has been delayed two weeks over
concerns the virus just isn't under
control all this as health experts
warned this holiday weekend could lead
to another spike in
cases even yesterday as the weekend was
getting underway there were signs on
some beaches that social distancing
might also take a holiday this Labor Day
weekend look at the behavior of the
University students okay and we don't
live in a communal Society we live in a
me Society Health officials are
concerned of a replay of what happened
after the 4th of July when there was a
22% Spike the average number of new US
cases reported 3 weeks after that
weekend the governor of Louisiana
reminded people Friday that after
Memorial Day the state was hit hard but
as we move into labor day I'm asking
every Louisiana and everyone who was in
Louisiana for any reason please be very
mindful of the fact that our last surge
started on Memorial Day weekend when
people let their guard down Coast to
Coast Governors are warning people about
the risks of not staying safe Kate Brown
is the governor of Oregon as we head
into the long weekend I do want to
remind oregonians across the state to
make smart choices when it comes to
covid-19 Across the Nation the number of
states reporting Rising numbers of new
cases jumped from 8 to weeks ago to 27
today people forget that we are battling
an invisible enemy and unfortunately
some let their guard down during these
times
in much of Northern California officials
aren't taking any chances many beaches
there will close this weekend people
flouting the rules but here's the
problem when they flout these rules
their selfishness not only kills people
but their selfishness kills our economy
scientists this week were put in the
spotlight as conflicting information
about the vaccine came out earlier in
the week the Centers for Disease Control
told states to prepare for distribution
as soon as late October then
Administration officials indicated that
may be ambitious it's extremely unlikely
but not impossible and therefore it's
the right thing to do to be prepared in
case and despite the CDC suggesting a
vaccine could potentially be available
just before the November election late
Friday the Wall Street Journal reported
that several top drug makers are working
on a public pledge saying they're not
going to seek government approval until
a vaccine is proven safe and effective
Michelle all right Michael thank you